menacés au début de la campagne,
à suivre également.
..c. VERIOf
- Ces élections provoquent
cardiaque chez Marcel Tanguay.
Autrement dit, son coeur
balance.
- J'suis membre du parti
québécois, mais j'aime bien la
là, c'est un souverain, enfin
pas souverainiste, c'est un
ancien souverainiste,
- C'est la ligue des aînés du
mardi matin, dans ce salon de
Nous sommes sur l'île Perrot,
à l'ouest de Montréal, dans la
circonscription de Vaudreuil.
le libéral, mais on sait jamaiss
qu'elle vient ici, puis elle est
Fait que je pense que c'est bon
(rires)
- Elle, c'est la candidatec,
ancienne directrice du Carrefour
Jeunesse emploi de la région.
EVE BÉLEC,
candidate, CAQ,
- En 2014, il y avait à peu près
20 000 vt entre les
Libéraux et la CAQ. Alors qu'en
2018, c'était autour de 2700.
Moi, c'earle, qui arle, qui arle
Vaudreuil veut du changement
- Et cette course a toutes les
chances de se résumer à un duel
avec la députée sortante
n Brossard."muscles et vitaminee
un quartier général libéral.Cel,
la présidente du parti.
LINDA CARON,
- Bien entendu, l'objectif,
c'est de garder La Pinière
dans le giron du Parti libéral
du Québec.
- Et de succéder ainsi
circonscription où les électeurs
ont un profil ethnique
très diversifié.
- Ce que je défendrais bec et
ongles, toujours,
- Mais là aussi, le candidat
de la CAQ guette ue
dans la cuirasse rouge.
(applaudissements)
au printemps dernier,
dans Marie-Victorin,
Shirley Dorismond de la CAQoins
de 800 voix sur Pierre Nantel.
Premièe ici d'un parti
autre que le Parti québécois
depuis 1984.
aujourd'hui sur le retour
des péquistes égarés.
- J'suis un ancien péquisse.
Et puis j'avais...
j'ai dit : "m'a essayer la CAQ".
Je vais voter pour
québécois.
- M'a vous dire po
premièrement, je veux punir
fermé lents, pournts, pournts, r
avoir fermé les centres d'achat.
- Ça vous a beaucoup affe
- Ça nous a privés de notrelibet
en santé.
- Quand j'entends "je retour
beaucoup de gens qui ont
ressenti une fatig
référendaire, une fatigue
relativement à l'indépendance.
Et puis ces gens-lense
des intérêts du Québec.
- Il esse
qu'ils n'auraient pas dû.
Et puis il y a la
de Laporte.
Là encore, la CAe PLQ.
Mais Québec solidaire y tente
une autre sortie de l'île
- C'est quoi les enjeux dansla ?
- C'est beaucoup le transport
qu'il l'est présentement.
- Celle qui veut prendre Laporte
pour les Solidaires était connu.
Pour l'ent d'abord.
Mais il y a d'autres enjeux dans
CLAUDE LEFRANÇOIS
- Inflation et logement.
Parce que même ici à Sai
Lambert, on a l'impression,
le préjugé que tout le monde est
riche. Le tiers deececececececec
50 000$ et moins par année
comme revenu famil
- Ces quatre circonscriptions
de la Montérégie sont celles
Un abat est possible pour
un coup
à la Marcel.
Ici Mathieu Prost Radio- Canad.